so reading from the hill it says
stung by their party's dis uh
dispiriting showing at the polls
on tuesday two moderate house democrats
say they and other centres
are privately discussing a plan that was
unthinkable just 24 hours earlier
throwing their support behind a
challenger to speaker nancy pelosi the
two democrats told the hill on wednesday
that they were reaching out to their
colleagues about backing one of pelosi's
top lieutenants
house democratic caucus chairman hakeem
jeffries for speaker in the house
congress
he's the only one prepared and
positioned to be speakers of one of the
democratic lawmakers he bridges
moderates and progresses better than
anybody
and most importantly he's not pelosi
although
apparently jeffrey shot down the idea
and said he's focused on on you know on
keeping his current spot
of course he has to say that here's and
i've been reading more about this and
you you we're seeing this more and more
that while democrats need to moderate a
little bit they need to start elevating
the centrists and moderates in their
party
the problem is that and this is a this
is a pretty big logistical problem
there are no centrists and moderates in
the democrat party
to elevate um i mean we
we might be down to like in the entire
democrat party across the entire country
there might be literally a hand well not
literally a handful uh there might be
you know a two or three or four or five
i mean it's it's there are very very few
of them
because this is what the democrat party
has become
is even the so-called anytime you hear
that someone is a
a moderate democrat well
ask them do they believe in any
restrictions for abortions whatsoever
do they believe in that it's okay to
kill infants up into the moment of birth
because they'll find even the moderate
ones hold that view which is an extreme
view
do they believe in pregnant men do they
think that men can get pregnant
even the moderate ones hold that view
these are radical extreme viewpoints
that even the the so-called moderate
democrats
uh subscribe to and that's going to be a
problem for the democratic party if they
want to moderate
they're always moderating in relation to
how far left they've gone so what is
centrist and moderate in the modern
democrat party
would have been wildly extreme left-wing
25 30 years ago
um number two election protests all
across the country and here's how
it went in new york watch
as you can see there she spits in the
officer's face uh is arrested
it's quite satisfying at least to see
her taken down and arrested hopefully
that disgusting trashy woman will be
locked in a cage for a long time you
know spitting on a police officer
already a crime doing it during a
pandemic should be even more of a crime
uh you know the charger is a biological
terrorist thrower in gitmo i'd be fine
with that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content